[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hey what's up guys it's me Eric that's
Joey you can see that in our names I
guess right down there below because we
have lower thirds and follow us on the
Twitter's but thank you guys for tuning
in we are checking out injustice to
today it has come out it's been out for
a while now I guess since like 9:00 p.m.
yesterday which is like 12 p.m. 12 a.m.
Eastern
Peter Brown's review is up it got a 9
out of 10 it's a solid solder spoiler a
solid solid amazing game that you can
read his review on gang squad comm have
that open on the side as we you watch a
stream as well we're gonna open up some
loot boxes Joey has been hoarding them
for like a week here let me let me show
you how many boxes yeah heaven I've
opened up all the bronze ones but that's
fine nobody likes bronze ones right um
so he's gonna okay you said you'd show
them a diamond right yellow show of one
diamond then we'll come back and open
these I guess right that fair yes that
sounds fun okay um why don't you do that
okay
best of luck to you going in it's got to
be good right it's gotta be like five
epics oh my god
it's a lot of stuff there I like it for
people that I don't even play
unfortunately that's one sounds like
it's like overwatch all over again
but the cool thing about the armors the
epic armors is that they have like set
bonuses yeah um which you can you know
have on during the multiverse which you
can also turn on and off to when you're
like fighting each other if you want to
you know do that otherwise it's like
aesthetic right yeah so that's really
cool um also just so you know I am
monitoring chat in YouTube twitch and
GameSpot if you guys have questions
we'll try to answer them to the best of
our abilities we will not do too much
story today so there won't be any story
spoilers we're mainly going to be
hanging out in the multiverse we're
gonna check out some of that will maybe
throw Joey into online battle I don't
know maybe we'll see how that goes
we'll definitely play each other uh that
is when I'm going to come to you guys in
the chat and say hey who do you think is
going to win me or Joey I'd like to
think it's a money match but I don't
know maybe it will be maybe it won't be
good
means sure uh but yeah thank you guys
again for tuning in if you haven't
already hit follow on the twitch please
help us do that so you guys know when we
go live or hit subscribe on YouTube for
that hot injustice to content as well as
on live streams as we go we're gonna
have them every day from now on
alright so here's like the multiverse
it's pretty much kind of like similar to
the living towers if you played Mortal
Kombat X or XL
why don't you I guess let's dive into it
a little bit more so some of them have
like modifier some don't you obviously
get rewards for playing through them
which is kind of cool because you can
get boxes and those boxes can sometimes
open into you got to do that info you
gotta do some of those are the ones so
it's like kind of locked away so here is
uh Joey's got it bad so that's your boy
hacker Bobby pack one two three is
already asking what characters are like
we can kinda tell I started on green
arrow first just because it seemed wow
yellow yellow arrow here uh you see my
level twenty also scarecrow is also one
of my favorites right now dude he's got
some really cool like armors and like
just like the look of him is pretty cool
like there yeah I feel like some of the
heroes look cooler than the others with
their uh epic sets and whatnot yeah and
then you also have those premiere skins
which Joey has also purchased we can
show you some of those there's like
reverse-flash
and some other characters or heroes like
I haven't equipped so if we if we play
the characters so green arrow and
Scarecrow for you so far I've been a
basic person I'm like in Batman Superman
dr. fate is actually really cool um I
haven't really gotten a complete hold of
how to play that hero well but he is
definitely a character that I want to
learn and hopefully get better at but uh
yeah I'm also curious if you guys have
picked it up today
you know like want to know what your
guys thoughts are in terms of like what
you played so far you know how your
liking maybe story mode or multiverse
etc you know please shout out in the
comments
and I guess I can give some shoutouts to
the people that wanted some shout out so
I think like let's see there's like BT
seven two seven four you got your boy
Dayton Erickson thank you guys for
tuning in we'll get to we'll play doctor
fate later I'll play doctor fate maybe
again show um be dog gamer are you stuck
to one character for the whole world so
the cool thing about story mode again
similarly as before you pretty much play
as um a couple different characters as
you go and progress through the story
and there's even times where you kind of
have an option to play one or the other
right yeah so like it as it goes it will
follow maybe a group of characters and
when they get to a battle at some point
sometimes you'll be able to pick between
like green arrow and black canary or
Batman Superman or just whoever's
incorporate into the story at the time
so you have a lot of different options
for for voice lines and whatnot yeah and
I mean just just so you guys know as
well um that can ultimately there's like
I think two endings that is that right
yes so there's two endings and depending
on like who you play or like how plays
out for you you'll get kind of a
different character and names
essentially or you know two different
endings so you have to do it gives you
the reason to go back and play as some
of those other characters when you have
those choices is that link is the super
II oh it does link black Adam Adam is
one of those characters I just don't
quite understand yet he's pretty cool he
was in the I'm pretty sure he was in
person justice as well watch dreams
Thank You Dana Erickson for saying yar
my favorite youtubers ever thank you I
would assume that's for me and Joey we
pretty me and Joey just pretty much do
streams where we open boxes that's our
call do it I guess but yeah we'll get to
opening up more boxes also another cool
thing if you guys have purchased
injustice or thinking about it there are
guilds in the online world and GameSpot
has a guild
I think we're ranked 2 we ranked number
2 in the world right back into nether
realm themselves so if you want to join
that I believe the clan tag is GS so if
you want to check that out and join up
because like there's also guild rewards
so you get you earn boxes through there
as well so yep Bob Jones loot boxes we
got a ton of them yes every time you I
think it's every time you log in
depending on how many people have played
through the multiverse in unlock stuff
you just get them automatically right
uh-huh I guess a new gear up in Mulqueen
asking should I buy this uh totally
depends I think if you are into fighting
games and even more so into like DC
Comics and DC heroes I think it's um
totally a good solid great game you know
nine out of ten from our reviewer here
at GameSpot Peter Brown I think it's I
think it's fun
what about you I think I really like it
it's weird for me because I can't my
background is not in like nether realm
games at all but like once I stopped
once I caught on to how to play it it
became really really fun like yeah so
for the for those of you who don't know
I guess Joey is a prolific I'll be
generally prolific Marvel vs. Capcom 3
players so you know we always were
joking like we you know when's marvel
and I guess I even saw you tweet today
like man there might be a point this
year where you think that injustice two
is gonna be the fighting game for you I
don't open it and you guys would be
really weird yet and yeah I've been like
a couple months ago I feel I feel almost
like kind of like
bad for saying it I guess like I'm a
traitor or something but it's like that
just goes to show you how good and
justice is well also what you saw wasn't
the entire game yeah that's a Marvel vs.
Capcom infinite he only saw like a
limited build but I mean he had a feel
for the gameplay and the style so I was
actually shocked to see that you wrote
that because I know you're a big Marvel
fan so it's interesting yeah it
definitely black X 7 in 69 in YouTube
chat saying way better and more complete
than SF 5 I will say just in terms of
all this stuff that you're getting with
injustice to at least on day one is
definitely like way more than all that
all that gear all like it's just all the
gear kind of contributes like built-in
costumes that you don't really need to
buy like or pay money for you just need
to unlock them pretty cool but also pay
for them like you did true be rock organ
will play some joker later I know I'm
not too familiar with him I don't know
if Joey is again I have a little bit
yeah yeah I have played probably like
six characters it's hard because for me
I don't necessarily jump character to
character I like to try to like get a
good feel of one character get some
combos get some bread and butters down
so that you know you're you're at least
competent when you play the doctor
instead of like oh I'm gonna jump around
to I mean like you can totally do that
though but still alright so we got in
the multiverse they have the modifiers
in some of the the challenges I'm not
sure with this one yeah I don't see the
others destiny has been cited near by
his dream stone power source will SAP
your will assume that means like health
yeah maybe but there are other ones like
low gravity like yeah yeah it's a weird
one once we were like the floor tilts
and like whoever's on the high ground
takes more damage mm-hmm I had one with
like Harley bombs just dropping randomly
let's see hello leo Oh door thank you
for the kind words and we will try to
keep streaming thank you a lot of people
a couple people mentioned uh there's a
good amount of skill in this game unless
you're Sonic Fox and you played that
shot oh yeah we saw that today uh sorry
Fox is one of arguably one of the best
Mortal Kombat X players out there so if
and he's playing
- obviously he is currently playing a
lot Deadshot and zoning people zoning is
very hard to deal with
if you don't exactly know what to do but
don't forget there are things like meter
burn role that allow you to roll like
pretty far across the screen you know
there are definitely tools in the game
it's it's day one you know a lot of
people are learning it is demoralizing
though to get just full-screen zoned the
whole time it was I watched about 12 to
15 minutes of it later mr. Michael 4:40
- thanks for stopping by
appreciate it
Colin coming saying I'm going from SF 5
to injustice and holy crap I have no
clue what I'm doing it definitely is a
different there's a change and just in
gameplay styles you you'll get used to
it though and get used to the timings
and once you do it'll feel a lot better
for you there definitely is a learning
curve though if you're coming from
Capcom games and you haven't played you
know too much Mortal Kombat or injustice
prior what's up Andrew brewer welcome
back a familiar face
thanks animal sensei your meaning
probably Green Arrow o or circa right is
territory more towards scarecrow just
because I played so much a green arrow
like in the early early multiverse
stages kind of a shake things up a
little bit mm-hmm oh good
for me right now I've been mainly
focused on Batman Superman they've been
working for me but I do want to learn
more dr. fate because I think he's a
really cool character and I look kind of
like his uh just how he plays a little
bit cuz he kind of zones a little bit
too in a weird way I don't know like
yeah a little bit yeah he um he's got
all those like little yeah projectiles
he's got like the meter burn you throw
three of them he get he regains health
if you put the like kind of like the
little bubble down but then his like
ability move triggers like damage
instead I don't clash enough that's
another thing well the thing is like if
we play against the people on the
computer a lot you're not really going
to get to I mean ideally just because
yeah I guess they don't combo well it is
you can only clash once you have the
second life bar
so if you're just beating them it's not
gonna happen really yeah uh how long a
story mode I think that was William
Munny
in YouTube chat I believe you said four
hours yeah about four or four to five
hours but it could be more to because
like we said you can do like the
alternate ending right yeah then like
you'd have to replay I don't know like
there are this like yeah but like I
think it's maybe like 10 or 15 extra
matches to get the second ending yeah so
probably you know five to six hours
potentially um so Brandon Thompson
asking do you guys like Marvel or DC
better I personally like just from a
like universe and not like just this
game wise or comparing like the fighting
games I personally like Marvel more I've
grown up with Marvel more so than DC I
would agree like a lot of the characters
in the Marvel games are a little bit
more recognizable in my opinion than
someone like Brainiac who I've actually
never heard of until this game yeah J
world Atrocitus is new to injustice in
terms of like injustice vs injustice -
and he's an interesting character - I
actually enjoyed him a lot in the beta
I haven't actually played him enough to
kind of get more of that so we'll see
philanthropy what's up man that's been
Janka one of our co-workers here at
GameSpot helping us mod chat so be nice
guys or he's gonna you know maybe bring
out the banhammer who knows thanks
animal sensei for the kind words black X
sub was 69 mentioning that you know that
you can kind of tell that there's a raid
in silhouette in the DLC trailer maybe
having a cosmetic costume of static
shock possible
hard to say they're having a bunch of
speculations on who some of the
characters could be though like one of
them was be maybe Beast Boy which sign
was kind of cool Beast Boy
yeah I'm sorry so for me I know some of
the Teen Titans oh I know who these boy
is that's the only way I know Beast Boy
and then it's cool to see Starfire in
the game because she's also from Teen
Titans at least I'm sure she's in other
stuff too but that's where I
recognize them also what I think wha one
of the silhouettes was he said The
Enchantress maybe
oh yeah there's easy any word I weren't
digging back because like I just think a
Suicide Squad and how she's like
gyrating you know like the whole time
she's talking and I can't take her
seriously cuz she's just like you know
seductively like kind of like sorry
Thank You Jeremy Garcia it says
gainsaying GameSpot come on you guys are
the best really appreciate that and you
tuning in consumers just got super what
is multiverse offline knows I add we are
playing in the multiverse right now oh
sorry
is it an offline feat a game feature yes
that's offline because the only two
things that were online when I thought I
couldn't play was like online obviously
and there was something else I was
locked out of I think the guilt stuff
yeah okay so will the there is a guild
multiverse mode which is online kind of
like you work together in order to earn
rewards yep
that's the other cool thing about
joining a guild is like I think just for
me like logging into the guild stuff I
got a bunch of boxes so it's pretty cool
to join a guild if you if you haven't
yet like I said there is one for
GameSpot if you want to do that your you
know you can also join other guilds but
um there's definitely a reason to do
that just get some free boxes come on I
wanna do my boxing glove arrow uh
someone will take care of that gods even
just this guy don't worry me and sonic
Fox agree that this fighting game is a
side-scrolling shooter you got it
gotta scare crow torso uh millaa millaa
rocks in YouTube chat asking what's the
best option if you're using the ps4
controller use the arrows at analog
stick I've always when I played on pad
because I'm a I'm a pad player I use the
arrows but I know that's not for
everyone
I like the arrows more than the analog
just because I can feel the direction of
what I'm doing more precisely I'm like
it's really difficult for me because
like I come from like I play on stick
and so when I when I need to use
controller I kind of I kind of go in
between both of
like in the middle of a match sometimes
like I feel like some moves will be
better for a stick and then some will be
better with the analog or the d-pad it's
kind of strange um Hamza is asking is
there any changes to the class system or
is it the same as injustice one I
believe it's the same from what I can
tell yeah but I'll let someone else also
and be chat kind of I still haven't done
that mind control move yet I don't know
what it does either do you know what it
does to you when you got the like I have
orb on your head I'm really not sure
okay what - look look for it uh can you
earn here playing it offline mode or do
you have to be online to unlock them ah
that's a good question Andrew brewer I'm
not sure because I've always been online
I guess the one weird thing I will say
though is so I don't know if you
experienced this Joey but I was doing
multiverse stuff here at work right yeah
and I got pretty far I did at like this
is day one I did all three tutorials and
then when I went home they do multiverse
it forced me to do all three tutorials
again even though it's it showed me that
I earned all the boxes so it's like hmm
weird in the sense that like the
multiverse didn't carry over I guess was
just your seat or like well my stable is
good though because all my credits and
my skins and stuff like that were there
or now my skin sorry my armor but for
some reason the multiverse part of it
where I completed certain stuff it
didn't have it registered for boat for
whatever reason but I didn't cloud save
and then download the safe so maybe it
was that's what I was doing - okay you
were doing that so it does work if you
cause save got it a country boy 7:06
says I really wish they would add a tag
system to this game the interesting
thing is there is tagged in multiverse
on certain multiverse planets um it's
interesting because like you'll have
like Batman's help or um black Adams
help I've had that like peoples's yeah
they do have a cyst which is like so
it's like maybe they're playing around
with the idea that maybe that's a thing
in the future I don't know dark wolf 2 4
5 any tips for Blue Beetle and scarecrow
they're my means I'll let him talk about
scarecrow I've only played blue beetle
in the
but uh he seems pretty solid with no
meter wonderful
hey Dublin but it stops a combo go true
right like that's part of the reason why
I like Peter was saying that too it's
like oh well why would you clash like
well you need to break a combo sometimes
oh my god
ninja LAN was saying stay mid-ranges
scarecrow yeah like you you just based
on his like shame you know it is kind of
long and it does have some reach he's
not really a long range character like
you want to stay within like striking
range because he doesn't have any
projectiles yeah well at least well
yours is what level is yours oh my so he
does have like extra ability yes so like
we that's something we didn't mention is
every character has a couple of extra
abilities you can unlock one at level 10
and a lock one at level 20 I believe I
don't get them drew you don't yet you
don't get them through the boxes and
those will actually change how some
characters play it so like I didn't
realize flash actually has a projectile
so I think that's an extra really yeah
he can throw a ball of light oh yeah
that's a pretty big deal because flash
has like kind of very like limited range
in my opinion like he's like like he's
all like in-your-face kind of like his
moves don't even like reach that far
from what I can tell um but yeah so that
changes the gameplay a bit obviously and
then it's also weird when you play
against someone that you don't like you
never seen that move and you're like oh
what the hell is that like today I saw
Robin for the first time with the stick
like Nightwing yeah instead of the sword
and he played differently so jean-luc
psyche also in our video producer here
also mentioned he had the same thing
with the multiverse it is local save
base so you want to definitely oh my god
go make sure you upload them if you're
playing in two different places I don't
have any tips for Atrocitus ninja but I
know he's a pretty damaging character if
you can pull off some of the longer
combos uh can you get the full robot
skin for cyborg I think it's possible
I've seen him without like the face oh
yeah you need to get the you to link the
mobile account
uh Andrew brewer the only thing that
character unlock wise that you get from
beating stories you get brainiac so
instead of how or you can pay $5.99 for
him yeah for some reason yeah if you
really don't feel like playing the story
mode yeah but you get yeah you get other
cool stuff from being story you get a
bunch of boxes you're leveling
characters as you go and I think that
it's probably a decent idea if you
haven't played too much injustice to do
the story mode because then it gives you
a feel for multiple characters and maybe
by playing through the story you're like
oh I really like how this character
feels and then you know you that becomes
your main or something um hanging on by
a thread here this one is they're
characters that can reflect the ring
goes hey reflect yeah or absorb um I
don't know of him yeah I haven't played
enough I guess to know enough characters
rather gods oh yeah Atrocitus is power
as a cat that can like do different
things and it'll extend combos and stuff
like that and or like help you trade I
think so that punching bag arrow does
like 300 damage it doesn't like to
something like that
the pen is maybe a little bit less
because of the multiverse stuff but it's
all I could have armed i yeah i know i
remember you showing it to me
ahh Butthead but butt-head says poison
ivy neck suggesting uh what we can do
later is when we play each other we'll
try to play some of the characters you
want but the problem is we are only
proficient in so many characters so that
gameplay might not look so hot just
putting it out there so you guys just
ahead of time like yeah but they want to
see like the Super's or just like kind
of the basic combos yeah you can you can
weaken by yeah when y'all doing that
loop box opening oh we can do it in a
little bit um just going through some
wall survived this multiverse gonna be
fine I'll play I'll definitely play
Superman Dayton cuz I'm running out of I
don't have that many characters to play
so I love to see a Deathstroke skin for
Desha I wouldn't be shoddy they didn't
have looked the same and yeah I would be
shocked if they did that Sam Canard is
we're in the game no he's not there's
speculation that through the silhouettes
through the DLC trailer they think one
of those silhouettes is Beast Boy but
it's really hard to say it's all
speculation at this point I don't know
the DLC characters outside the ones that
have been announced and or the
speculating of the silhouettes I think
one of them is definitely Raiden though
unless there's some character that
happens to look just like Raiden because
the Hat is too like on point yeah work
on my wake up it's a wake up is
interesting in this game to like I have
to remind it's kind of weird and then
there's like a quick roll right you have
to hit like is it square or whatever as
you fall took through the quick roll
look you know how like there's like the
quick get up or whatever instead of like
the delayed one yeah oh I think you just
hit any button and like right when you
land it's just like a tech for like
scream better or something and Chad a
thousand six in switch asking what
characters are y'all trying to get gear
for new man um that's the thing about
playing the multiverse man you like see
like you keep fighting all these other
you know the AI and they have all the
built costumes you're like man I want
that I want that too and how do I get
that and thing is like these are set
items right so it's hard because you
want to try to make the set the same
which you can kind of do with the like
that I I want to call a
transmogrification because of Diablo
triggers that transform where you can
make them look the same and then you can
also do a regen which allows you to kind
of like bring another piece of gear that
you really like look and stats to like
your level but then it might have
different stats super no shame no shame
no shame
so I know you actually unlock the
alternate super yes Superman Superman I
don't know how many other characters
have it yeah II wonder is sure has a
variant on his super so like I think
instead of discharging you forward and
hitting you he does like a meteor drop
from above instead which is kind of
jarring the first time you see it cuz
you didn't think to block it block it
because he just disappears from the
screen all of a sudden clashes oh static
right she's saying actually in a newer
image of the silhouettes Raiden is no
longer there
whoo who knows then I didn't know that
I've only seen the DLC were like the
silhouettes at the end but trying to
play us Robert Matthews saying I miss
Sinestro yeah I could see that but now
you have Atrocitus the Red Lantern is
that ah almighty peen pain oh why do you
pee pee nor pain just receive my game
like five minutes ago can't wait to play
it glad you got a hold of it and hope
you enjoy it
Oh anti-air armor rollers armor - maybe
you're beating her up oh he knows so
we'll a modifier more a meter yeah this
knows that modifier thing I'm here Coria
saying haven't have to wait till my
birthday well I hope your birthday is
not too far away and that you get to
hear okay rip oh now ninja lime was
saying rating is still there but he
doesn't have his hat that makes sense
that would make it less obvious but how
can you it how can you tell this him
without his hat almost say maybe the
silhouette saying except there's no hat
hey it's me also saying ratings still
there okay are you gonna recognize him
without his hat is Black Manta they're
all Black Manta was pretty noticeable
too like the head shape I think it was
or the Hat shape whichever one it was
hello Jennifer you're out there
I feel like you've asked me to do this
before to say to say your name but
there's your shoutout
you're not getting another one
b-dawg gamers saying I'm on the bus
heading home from school thanks for
tuning in after school the school is
important appreciate you watching in the
in on the bus though and he's saying my
digital Batman Edition is just finished
downloading
can I get a shoutout there's a shout-out
Man for the hope that is done
downloading by the time you get home if
not keep watching til it's done right
IGN kept playing Batman yeah so console
hot 92 I know why IGN kept playing
Batman for so long is because destined
Legare e's main is Batman he smoked me
in beta because he knew what he was
doing he probably would still win six
times out of 10 on me I would think
because I'm not super great but I feel
like if we we fought again pretty more
it would be more even but yeah the
reason they played a lot Batman is why
because um that's destined character
this Wonder Woman is ooh
why is 0 0 o MJ ask what do you think
red hoods place that will be yeah I
don't know he's got a gun oh you've got
a gun it's always oh it's hard to say
because it's like is will he play more
like Harley Captain Cold
Joker you know those characters are like
a dead shot well Deadshot has two guns
full depending how you look at it
because he's good he got five guns
for all we know yeah ninja Lama thinking
that Red Hood will be a mid-range
zoner with a few grapples and Sons life
interesting is there Batgirl not
confirmed not that we know was she I
think she was deal seeing injustice one
she came out later I think yeah I think
so what voiceless shooting slightly they
were slightly confused by the story like
I won't talk too much about story
because I don't want to spoil for anyone
I hope you're blocking yeah got a punish
there you go
run away Thanks been Janka says I've
been Destin I think you beat him too
uh I like didn't have enough injustice
knowledge when I played the first time
around in beta so he was definitely
whooping me but when he played a new
character that he didn't play so not
Batman I was able to beat him so it's
like character familiarity and stuff
like that
stack right you also confirming Black
Manta is still there in the silhouettes
thank you for that does a gear bus work
online yes if you leave it on I guess if
you guys agree to keep the gear buffs on
right yeah so like if when you when you
go into a ring or I think it's if you go
into a player match it'll ask you before
you start if you want to keep the gear
box and I think both people need to hit
to agree oh yeah yeah thanks but if you
do like a if you do a ranked match will
automatically turn it off gotcha I mean
there's a pretty significant difference
if you're fighting like a level twenty
at like five if your gears on it's
actually like the damage output is
insane and you do a lot less damage
v-dog gamer and country boy saying
thanks for noise wars yep no problem
Amir Coria can't wait to play sub-zero
that's gonna be interesting see how that
plays out how long until we get like all
the mold combat casts in here uh there
won't be that maybe there's just gonna
be some krauser almighty I'm mighty pain
or pain sorry if I'm butchering the last
part of your name there
they said spawn might be coming to the
game soon that would be cool um I would
like to see that I always thought I was
a pretty cool character you member spawn
the Soul Calibur - yes but I never liked
the hey Boxey yeah I never played him
remember spawn the movie with John
Leguizamo as soon as the clown oh that's
great movie I want them to do a reboot
spawn but I don't think there's enough
interest probably um Nathan Loden asking
who our mains are and then following up
is Green Arrow's main I think Green
Arrow and Scarecrow for him for now
that's who he's been playing and then
Superman Batman for me so yeah uh oh my
god Jamie Knight 4016 I just picked this
game up hype
yeah there's been some definitely some
hyper on the character are you greeting
me you want oh no no she's not good I
never know have you got a lot of new
abilities yet for your other characters
cuz I had like a couple where I had to
UM I have scarecrow has to actually
scarecrow is all furry I think no but
notes no super yeah I don't think his
changes have have Robins like low
birdarang I think you got that uh sack
wood how do you perform state transition
so you need to do back exertion back
three uh you know one two three four is
for do it for those that don't know I
guess in fighting games like light
medium hard and then character ability
but like it's a X or three you do back
and you have to be like a certain
distance you have to be you know that
the you know on the sides of there's
like a specific wall in each stage like
not all stages have the transition but
the ones that do they'll do either have
it on the left or right you just kinda
have to do yeah and then there's also
technically that other kind of stage
transition but not really transition
with a stage like not environment I
guess it counts as environment we're
like you can hit them off and then they
come back and get combo
yeah like brainiacs stage you can like
hit him into Brainiac Brainiac like hit
you with his to like tentacles and sends
you back yeah just like the
environmental hazards yeah this one was
out I heard someone asking for loot
boxes
alright let's do it what do you alright
so we're going to spare you silver and
bronze cuz usually there's not that much
stuff and we get bored with gold then
you know go died is what it is but we'll
go diamond platinum after that so once
you start opening some boxes we'll try
to keep reading questions Jacob over
cursed why is being arrow yellow it's
because there's also um they're not
skins right there shaders shaders their
shaders like a like destiny they got
shaders thank you ninja llama uh here we
got a green lantern shader
nice common three CFM gave me a crazy
funny moment gamer that's a long tag and
YouTube just got they got injustice to
you and they can't wait
I don't play too much firestorm I got a
law firm now oh yeah he lives in that he
or she lives in the UK thanks for
joining us from the UK really appreciate
it
how do you get platinum and diamond loop
boxes so platinum you can get some from
wow you have some good stuff there yeah
but no no no I feel like it's like the
overwatch mentality there's like you get
this the the armors for the other
characters that then kind of makes you
feel like oh I should try those other
characters yeah uh fine um you can get
for sure in the multiverse or certain
multiverse worlds that you can complete
certain tasks or achieve a certain score
and you'll get a platinum box diamond
you said you got one from beating the
game yeah and then there's like a dark
side multiverse yeah there's no one from
that they're like side of diamond this
is the same idea that you'll get from
multiverse stuff but they're I guess
they're just a little more rare or like
some of the really tough multiverse
battles right yeah my all for one and
that and the cool thing about the some
of the multiverse is that all right
we're gonna use some dead shot like we
got a trophy um I just lost my train of
thought because I got distracted by loot
loot boxes diamonds man What's Up boss
crow 13 I think it can you customize
gear after this yeah we can go through
some characters and and show you guys
what we're talking about skins wise
premier skins um maybe some regenerating
maybe some transforming just so you guys
get a feel of how that works we can
definitely do that
scarecrow hook that's yeah but you got
an epic hooker oh yeah yeah well scroll
through some of the cool epic gear that
Joey has he's got some I've got some
online so yeah King a two of the same
gear I'm not sure I haven't had that
happen um they usually have a different
name yeah and they have different stats
too so I'm not you could yeah so even if
you get a different the same named one
they don't have like restraint like
there's four stats there right like that
could have different stats and I guess
in the augment - all right right right
um I guess what else could you do with
that you can technically sell it for
credits which it says there also
I don't know what else you would do with
the other than that sell it or you can
sacrifice it to your deal right so one
of the the multi-verse guild things is
like sacrifice 100 Commons so you maybe
you have that this green arrow have any
hoods ask Jesus fernandez do you have
any hood x' event singer or i have a
piece and have a baseball hat that i
have hun right now um he has some other
masks I don't I don't think I've seen a
hood yet okay
and Chad thousand six is it easy to get
six thousand source crystals for
premiere skins um it's not necessarily
hard I I've gotten about six thousand
now from just playing a lot of
multiverse I'm sure if you did the
single-player story mode and did some
multiverses you'll be able to get at
least one premier skin in like a decent
amount of time Joey's got a hundred
seventeen thousand because he he bought
some for the stream we did it for the
stream uh I think I have this already
did you do you you still get gear in
local split-screen right yeah yeah I
think I should you should because like
you get gear from doing um single fight
right or is that just experience will
test you later whatever sound gear as
you level up maybe yeah uh the gears
total random though uh yes there is a
Perigord yeah zero McLain there is a
power girl premier scan for Supergirl
but not a standalone character
fortunately okay alright we got one new
soul twenty boxes that's fine keep going
we're reading chat yeah you're getting
epics though look get our dead shots
gonna look sick he's gonna have all
these epic pieces uh hashtag for the
streams says be dog gamer look dude
the poison I'm mad don't be mad at your
luck okay sometimes my gold boxes are
worse than this uh can you get a lot of
gear and also level up in offline mode
uh not sure how like in terms of how
much gear you can get I think you can
still get a decent amount leveling up
actually it's really fast in if you're
trying to power level a character I feel
like one of the fastest ways is to do
single fight against the AI and actually
just put them on very easy and just like
destroy them yeah even you get chunks
even more than the multiverse
um I just I just feel like it's faster
because there's not as much like loading
in between you're getting retry and just
like oh very very easy character just
don't do something stupid like I did I
put my level toy at first I was just
spamming and I put my level 20 Superman
they're like why am I not really have
someone else before yeah I so fast
Oh as the opponent yeah yeah here's
level 20 and I was like level 1 Batman
trying to like level up my Batman it was
like Oh what the hell Oh cuz he's my
level 28 Superman that's why he's using
a fight stick I play on a gamepad you
can do either one totally up to you it's
all just matter of purpose there's a
scarecrow yellow lantern skin that's
like gaming my 40 set 46 said I don't
know I'll have to check it out later
um oh yeah John Luke brings up another
good point you can actually um set up AI
loadouts on your your heroes and then
you can pit those AI uh heroes that you
have and like play against other
people's AI euros and you can speed that
up look for time you just get like loot
boxes that way yeah we'll show you that
too we'll show you that too it sounds
weird when I say that but yeah um how do
you link here and just this to mobile to
the game I believe there's a menu option
yeah here and then when you go into the
game on your phone you just go into the
options and say link to console and then
you just put in the code and then you
get the illicit cyborg skin yeah that's
a cyborg skin ah Mathu Anderssen each
character has a bunch of different armor
sets only some currently have premier
skins every character has a shade has
set a shader though so the armor sets
are what changed the look and feel of
your your character but um the premier
skins you can't change even if you
change the armor is what we found out
today it's just whatever the premier
skin looks like um cat
Katalin Caitlin Caitlin maybe with the
scenes God Catalan or Caitlin Bindu
hello will it get a PC port I haven't
seen anything related this I haven't
heard anything about that have you I
just know that Mortal Kombat PC port was
not very hot really I had some problems
for sure and then it eventually got
fixed but yeah can you test the offline
and whether or not you get gear yes
Corbin we'll check that out later we're
kind of going through some stuff going
through the boxes the next thing to do
will be to customize some OC so there's
a more leak window we're going to go
through the characters and just
customizing those um then we got to show
some AI stuff then we'll play some
matches against each other you want to
test the waters for online ad ah I don't
know that's up to you man
oh this is one you have yeah that belt
buckle that sweet belt buckle is their
gear for premiere skins no it just
changes your character to look like the
premiere skin and then you switch
whatever armor but you switching armor
doesn't actually change it there's no no
cosmetic changes once you have the
premiere skin on finest forma shooter oh
what's this one wow that's a lot of
that's a thirty really JD Star City cap
wow that is Wow everything is a plus
it's in the green ah
Dayton Eriksen got against why do you
guys play with fans sometimes we do um I
think for this stream I don't know if
we're going to do too much of that but
like I said we're gonna start doing
streams every day um hopefully some of
that includes some community stuff ooh
what's this what's this what's this is
something more than just a cape oh it's
a cape I swear okay so this is the third
Superman a head that I've seen it
doesn't do anything to that his actual
head and his I swear to god the capes
all look the same they they all look the
same
well it's got like a little uh no oh if
you if I could show you mine they all
look the same
are you gonna open the guild mother
boxes here alright and then we're gonna
do some platinum
oh man your gold is pretty lucky man
pretty local man arms cyborg torso want
you open up some some of those platinum
platinum ones
give me some platinum all right crown of
Atlantis how's that look it's a crown
yeah I think the other cool thing too is
like I mentioned earlier as though is
that they're set bonuses yeah so if
you're able to get like epic sets
together and we'll show you that in
character customization it they actually
trigger different things which is kind
of cool because as Peter has talked
about it's it's got that strangely
enough this game has like an RPG element
yeah all right go for latinum oh that
was kind of not Latin to me that's fine
more epics almighty a mighty peen saying
you can correct me if I'm saying that
wrong by the way because it gonna be P
nor pain I wish more Teen Titan
characters were they in this game you're
already getting one for sure Starfire
and you might be getting a second if
that really is Beast Boy that's like and
yeah Robin that's three there's just no
I in your cyborg Jesus what am I saying
you're gonna have all five almost I was
like wait where's all right that's like
all of them uh mere Coria asking do you
think Cosby would be asking for the
flash I'm not sure I don't know enough
about DC lore so I apologize for that
I'll just be upfront and honest about it
what was that was that platinum oh here
we go
let's go diamond diamonds go diamond
give us five ethics for four is good for
is good we got a switchblade Joker
does it look that different though oh
yeah it's got some ridges Ruby oh this
is the cat a cat yeah it changes a cat's
the armored line last one last time in
last diamond here we go how do you get
gilt coins I think you got to do that
through all I was a weak box yeah I got
a nice hero card background now
his helms are pretty cool trosset is
Jacob I don't know which characters are
Opie if you want to follow us on a fox
the I think he's ranked number one he's
just playing a lot of dead shot keep
away right now but I'm sure he could
play a lot of characters but it's
definitely working for him
alright those are all the gold gain
erickson we did black ops 3 live earlier
actually we did some zombies with the
developers that is a Avadh that you can
check out if you want to clip that at
eleven o'clock alright why don't you do
some character customization alright
let's check this out uh werewolf uh in
terms of the actual gameplay I mean like
the style of the game is still very the
same in terms of like the fighting game
mechanics I mean there's just different
heroes and different abilities obviously
and then with the loot system it does
change some things for you know your
online play with like the multiverse and
whatnot that's not a set huh she just
equip it anyways level 20 yeah I get
that
so level 12 so here you can see the
augments oh dang look at those ABS got
like Batman ABS like he has like 20 of
them on the sides of him oh my god
oooh Kelly Nelson that's a that's a
tough one guess what do you think
NetherRealm has surpassed Capcom when it
comes to fighting games I don't know if
it's tough I mean mechanically I still
feel like I like Capcom games war yeah
like in terms of just like the fluidity
of combat yeah but I feel like in terms
of like the package that you're getting
with injustice - yeah it's like a lot
better for like like everyone as a game
but like as a fight as a fighter I would
say Capcom they excel in like mechanics
I think like footsies are always really
good with with Capcom games but this is
their there they're putting putting a
lot of work for this for injustice yeah
I mean like just the the you know having
a single player having you know
multiverse like all these different
things just it's weird to say like it's
it caters to a wider audience
obviously right it's for everybody it's
like it's not that Street Fighter
I for example isn't for everybody it's
just that there's more in the game for
somebody that isn't as like hardcore
yeah right like I don't know that's kind
of Lee won all this year all this cool
stuff they they have that here there's
like a street fighter they they don't
they'll have a skins you can buy skins
but they have skins but they don't have
anything close like the gear acquisition
system in here this is Marcel we will be
doing a review of the Serge
I'm pretty sure oh that was this nice
skin this one sacrificial stone yeah so
these are all the shaders some are
common some aren't but you can buy some
oh yeah you got a lot of crystals huh
you can buy this or those are the source
crystals right yeah which you can earn
or purchase so yeah would you like
injustice to more or Mortal Kombat X ooh
this question right I liked Mortal
Kombat X quite a bit and I think that if
I had a bigger affinity for DC I I would
probably like injustice to more but I
think if you're just asking me between
Mortal Kombat X and injustice to I have
a bigger affinity for wow your Batman
looks cool or more combat
oh yeah the billionaire's cowl but it's
only level 1 man yeah but look look so
cool you'll be the only word to increase
your XP and credits billionaire suit so
there is a oh let me get rid of the PIP
really quick um there is your step bonus
you have a fluent if you wear two pieces
or where there's two affluents there's
one wearing two pieces you get um more
credits and guilty 5% more credits if
you wear all five and then yeah you got
cool the batarangs man you can make it
really guys we got mine these ones all
right but the thing is that it doesn't
have any like doesn't have great stats
yeah well you could read it it oh I
can't wear that little over this cowl
yet okay
yeah so basically this kind of lets you
customize your Batman a little bit more
do you want more strength ability
defense health you know Oh carbon fiber
damp braces I wish they were more
powerful too or I could just yeah you
can just
wow it's let it's worse than your other
one ginger sure he'll care because I
like the spikes yeah the spikes uh
wasn't that it wasn't the Christian Bale
one when he shot it at Joker he shot
those at Joker I felt like this
something like yeah is there Batman
Beyond gearset I don't know I really
hope there is Batman Beyond was one of
my favorite cartoons animated series
when I was growing up Terry McGinnis I
think they had that as a skin for the
first injustice to me
but they had that for Robin maybe it
might be misremembering I remember
something Batman Beyond max fo how fast
do you gain new loot you get blue pretty
frequently um now is it something you
know you necessarily want not
necessarily because it's random right
and there's so many characters and so
many different tiers of loot that you
know it's gonna be wow PAP man's got
some nice shaders he has more shaders
than oh no he has like most of everyone
bias
speaking of bias that was another thing
when you play like the multiverse you
can turn on like the character loot drop
bias which is right like it'll give you
more gear for the character that you're
currently playing
yeah or you can turn that off and just
get random yeah stuff yeah what's up can
you turn the blood off is there even
that I don't you - no no Super Nintendo
Batman Power Ranger style so good what's
a good one for oh you're gonna get me
one sick I don't know not that not army
but I like one of those blue ones yeah
like oh yeah I know that oh gee Batman
alright well we'll play a game in a
second emraan we're just doing we're
trying to check some boxes off different
people want to see different things
yeah cyborg has the uh are you gonna
show us some hot premiere got the grid
looks like terminator oh so they're just
alternate colors that's unfortunate
yeah so there's no like customization
with the premiere schemes like if I were
to go to his helmet like couldn't change
anything like they all look the same
why don't you show some more premiere
skins oh yeah yeah we'll go through
flash to an Chad don't worry flash got
that reverse flash so you don't have to
play multiplayer to get the gear Latino
you can Latino fire Latino on fire 77
sorry YouTube chat you can earn them in
multiple ways multiverse single fight
I think single fight we got a we got a
confirm one single fight but a
multiverse story mode there's a plethora
of ways to get gear there's your
reverse-flash
oh there's always okay there's boats
here's a question you bought the
reverse-flash oh you okay this is in a
colorway thing I'm sorry did you get
both colors when you bought the premiere
skin or did you have to purchase both
you get both okay at least there's that
um alright cool show some Harley Quinn
can you customize cheetah she's my
favorite maybe we'll do that after this
Corben
we'll check out Harley Quinn so this is
what I have her right now alright yep
that's about right you can change our
guns guns almost got little blades there
now she got like a mini gun on the front
um yeah Michael we'll get to some poison
ivy gear here in a second Cheers which i
answ maybe was arm to the hips these are
new Kelly Nelson asking do you think
it's a good idea for another room to
create mortal combat versus injustice
game that rivals Marvel vs. Capcom um in
a way they're kind of doing that already
right they're adding so Kate yeah there
was that whole MK vs. DC game a few
years ago I think that was like their
first grand experiment with like the DC
Universe if I'm not mistaken and then
justice came and then they did more
combat so they've been like switching in
between the two the last few years who
knows we'll see all right like nothing
on that's a real basic top yep different
hats just out yep
got the goggles I'll give her this one
okay there you go beautiful reverse - as
you know comedy is not a separate
character it's just like a different
skin or shader I guess is a technically
shader uh poison ivy sticks almost a gia
- yeah and then dr. Fayette later -
green arrow says green arrow oh that is
a oh you bought it yeah just straight X
okay
there's vixen we'll also look at
scarecrow we'll try to get through as
much as possible so you want to take
that off so you can equip her some of
her stuff
Scott love like horns and horns and
things and then she had like armed
bracers stuff - I think yeah put any of
the song yeah cuz you're sorry like we
can still show it though right yeah
it'll let you show it but these these
are we don't know when they're coming to
PC it's all right
got some reps Lana no cure is profile
lock let's say I start a game on my
profile my bro logs on for local will he
have to use my gear slash builds or will
we have access to it zones I'm not sure
about for local we'll find out we can
find out when we do our matches poison
ivy
dr. fate don't have a premiere skin I
haven't played enough Brainiac classy
badgers that's going to be a tough one
you're gonna have to beat single-player
or by Brainiac Chris $5.99 though what
is the difference here voice the stream
saying peep stop requesting so we can
get on some matches uh just a few more
characters show that guy Green Arrow
yeah we've seen a lot of green arrow
though who's a decent characters start
with says Harve dot s Batman Superman
are both pretty solid base starting
characters I don't want to say they're
like Ryu Ken but you know they have
pretty pretty like good core movesets
yeah and you can pull off a bunch of
combos and stuff like that so show Grodd
Blue Beetle honestly I wish grog was
cooler cuz I got kind of like a like a
cool character but well I mean maybe
just as gear is now
impressive I don't like his belt buckles
and stuff in his Helms it's like they
all kind of look the same
well that's because you don't have that
many uh can you buy loot boxes or not
you can buy them with credits which I'm
assuming you can probably buy credits
yeah but you also earn credits like a
lot of intricacies but you'd only buy up
to gold I think I don't even buy
platinum or diamond with credits yeah
all right that's enough garage do you
have anything cool for blue beetle cuz
he looks pretty cool when you get cool
stuff yeah I'll hit the 15 pieces like
his Helms get pretty crazy like is he
like that looks like a man like Ultraman
stuff this one's the same thing like you
remember that show beetleborgs no I
don't you don't it was like it's like a
I'm a lot older remember doing well I
mean it was like it's still in the 90s
though and those like a Power Rangers
Styles like or power influence show with
like this beetle man that had this huge
Shin that kind of like Jay Leno but he
want you okay what about your Ted mix
there what does that look like
okay now the boots don't ever seem to
make that much of a difference to be
honest the arms can though
because like I think the arms effectives
shoulders too not these ones okay maybe
not and then the Scarab play some math
edge Gotham City sirens style ah the
tick I remember the tick job oh yeah the
tick you didn't buy Darkseid right uh
yeah I did oh you did $5.99 okay cool so
that was Lotus once you show them that
real quickly the AI think oh yeah
because that only takes like a second
anyways so here's another way for you to
earn gear without actually even having
to play you can watch AI stuff fight in
sped-up mode yeah so you can customize
your a I basically doing the same kind
of loadout but specifically for your AI
characters and then you just go fight
and then I'll give you like a list of
like random people that like have them
on the surface
this guy right here that person has like
a level 8 that man a level 2 Superman on
level 1 Robin
so my attacking teams is already preset
it's a couple times oh man you're gonna
roll this guy you got top tier the the
cool thing about it is that it doesn't
matter really how powerful you are
because you won't it does all the things
if you lose you'll still get stuff yeah
yeah so watch this is us watching this
no no do it do it four times okay we can
speed this up a little bit so look we're
watching a match between our AI versus
Indy nine seven zero Ilocos AI somehow
we're losing at level 15 oh we want okay
thank God so it's best to or three um
and he earned XP there embrace your your
Kiner and gear t right it's random each
match um or is it after the after the
two out of three I think it's after okay
um you can also customize the characters
um like tendencies you can have be like
heavy rush down characters or like more
zoning not that you can really see
what's going on yeah we can see it this
is exactly how we play real fast hello
boxing-glove arrow your favorite and
your spamming yeah victory until we win
oh we didn't get any gear there after
the first five that you do every day you
look old mother boxy gets boxes and we
didn't do anything we just hit X a
couple times alright so um what do we do
now did I miss anything
oh you want to play if you feel that you
want to play so they say you guys wanted
to matches oh do I have to log on to
thing then oh yeah I think you just
press the PS button okay and just pick
you know yeah ah John Luke you've been
exposed alright uh so you bought a video
game to watch it play itself darn right
we did neurosis as long as we get gear
for it I'm going to try to dr. fate you
but we're gonna have to turn off gear a
model
okay that's fair enough looks like a
Benny Hill skit at that speed
yeah also turn competição here you can
do press l1 you can turn competitive
mode on and I advanced hit all the gear
and then oh it's square there you go
there you go so you can turn off
competitive mode let's go to return yeah
yeah on turn okay it's good Batcave
oh I guess you've played your kick pros
like a bat cave all right let me try oh
no argue is this default oh yeah you
might you want you to change it yeah and
Joey got them some funny buttons here
let me see hold on what Jax yeah okay
I'm good you're good even with like
triggers oh I would assume it's all
default
let's hope oh no it's so different no no
so I can get these these crosses and if
all three of all three of them hit
you're gonna get hit by label I was like
I am or the doctor Street little bubble
I heal from it so you don't want me to
you can have two of those at one time
I'm crispy combos gonna heal myself no
you can place the the heel behind you
and then if I use my character ability
it does like damage instead meter burn
oh my god that was some oh my god hits
on both sides some like pizza cutter
zero stuff he does have his own pizza
cutter right here oh did you need to
burn that yeah oh you did ah how dare
you play your Mane against my low tier
okay it's also if you're fine it's fine
it's fine I have confidence in my doctor
fate oh shoot got clash available ooh I
got my Shang Tsung ability well having
these fire arrows at all get zoned ah
gets owned dead shot I'm dead shot fine
ah no and then only you got activate
those those orbs on me or something
stay in my healing oh no oh that's silly
Oh see it does different things when
you're when you activate is the ability
oh no not like this can't clash that oh
you hit on the other side what's the
heck it's gonna be fine guys
you're pressing a button
oh I ran into that I just trying to heal
yeah that's right get day one doctor
faded you want switch carriers yeah all
right I'm looking at all right you guys
tell me who you guys want me to play
I'll try my good we lit up the chats I'm
not proficient in many of these
characters fate seems like he has a bevy
of options yeah definitely does have
some options scarecrow you play
scarecrow you know how to proko
I'm waiting I'm waiting for my call
who's it gonna be
I only know how to play like pork well
hopefully someone's a Superman Chuck no
I don't even know what is ha ha ha ha ha
character trait does do you have to do
it like three times I think it does I'll
play flash next neurosis I think give
them speed okay let's speed up I think
okay all right feeling good about it
everyone ready select don't be mad why
should we should let those play out huh
okay that doesn't work at ignores okay
got my gun oh that's so he has a I think
I chose a model I think it's back back
forward uh or down back to right it's
all right yeah I think one of his combos
is three to three that's a good one
oh now now whoo he's got a knife on his
on his toesies oh man I'm just trying to
get a good laugh off
oh you cancelled the garden I didn't
know you could cancel the gun all right
cancel into what though I know I think
it's just you can cancel it to like fake
it okay like - back or something yeah I
feel like throws are very like they're
just not that powerful in this game at
all
mmm I think it's more to like make the
other players think about it right
yeah oh I could see that
I don't do that doesn't have like a
command grab that like like pounds you
with it's the Khobar oh that's a I think
down forward three that's not that down
back three one knows I'm sure we'll
figure it out or figure it out back
forward maybe you think it's three
though yeah oh god yes unlockable by the
way back for three it was yeah I got
combos call me the Joker the joke's on
you I'm gonna get on with this chat you
get on with it
come on yeah that's right two dogs are
we gonna get him with the Shaka next
please play Superman guy in the black
shirt that's me Eric
I'll play Superman thanks for letting me
show some combos Deadshot you don't want
to see Deadshot where we just like shoot
across the screen like two minutes
someone and antoine been smooth says he
thinks that Harley's high-tier for show
if you know how to play with her
could be John Luke likes a Harley quite
a bit uh the maker iTunes livestream oh
this was a joke they just kept playing
Batman over and over because they
couldn't win with any Wells yeah but I
like I said Batman's their main probably
and like you know you don't want to pick
characters that you're not familiar with
especially when you're not playing
against each other we're like Joey gave
me some leeway were they were they
playing online mostly I don't know not
sure
Oh
Corbin he was shooting back in Corbin
here just being nice there
play play for real like for real Joey
I'm going to show you I'll show you my
Superman de I remember how to play God
dang it
OOP the kids owned oh shoot
that's not safe
by the way fiames yeah it blocks good
locks get blocks stage transition one
get run over the edge has a new -
strokes is Cal Nathan yes quite sure ah
I see you can't be spam in there if I if
I landed that punch after oh yeah I
should know better
it's the same combo Joey I gotta use the
power power of my Kryptonian blood oh no
I'm not talking to that overhead oh
there is chip damage
how's your camping normals my captain
cold is not good
oh how did yours be mine your aunt is
here a day is better than mine
apparently oh here he comes guys I still
haven't found like a good way of landing
his uh his super other than like a wall
bail do something oh no I keep missing
the freeze the freeze is so key
Hey
we haven't clashed once I don't clash
oops I should have said that supergirl
actually is pretty good Antoine um
because she also has the fries I'll play
Blue Beetle in a second um I know some
combos green arrow
I just can't land them right now my
robbing is awful
real talk my robbing is awful I'll shoot
him Batman
yeah that's right let's finish this one
I'll play back Oh teleport for
oh that's supposed to I was supposed to
punch you three times and then grab you
I'll play some Batman don't worry Lance
one of the too charactery characters
that I sort of know how to play yeah
oh let me try that corner traveling like
that one streamer whoo whoo got
scarecrow combos all that floaty jump
your meter burn oh yeah that's right I
was throwing too
dang look at what having a drink
Oh Santa is so much faster than this is
gonna hurt
oh that's what's the link
oh yeah oh this is the only way I can ya
know it scratches the back come on
okay we got him guys Wonder Woman is
actually pretty good to Eddie
yeah she's actually pretty good I got
dominated by a like good one in the so
we haven't gotten any loot huh we've
been getting credits and we've been
getting experience I haven't seen any
gear yet though so for whoever was
asking earlier I haven't seen any gear
yet can we go Batman
I'll go super me yeah go back in oh no
no no hon where's my swag Batman oh I
don't have your loadout no day one so
okay so can you log in on yours oh
that's really weird all right so that
questions been answered I don't get any
of the loadouts he has even though we're
playing on his PlayStation I want to but
the thing is I wonder if you were to
download yourself onto here I still
don't think so I think it's your safe oh
well I guess I'll be the cool Superman
dark side versus Blue Beetle I play Blue
Beetle Oh flash right I'm supposed to
play flash we'll play some flash in a
second
all right I really shouldn't have killed
the Joker
I did it for Louis it's not what she
would have wanted wanna do a Superman
you do that let her burn and you do that
oh yeah oh don't bounce that high ah
what's the - I got that Krypto could
kryptonite dig it
these boys not in this game yet oh shoot
that has so much delay
do that one what do on those combos
today one struggles of the Cephas oops
yeah you're going back to jail man
Oh as a peri oh you want to do in your
marble - my supposed to do they're here
oh I think Hey
oh no can't let a solid thing here oh
maybe you know you should play Batman
right cuz you know how to play Batman
like not not that well oh all right uh
new characters what did you get I show
look at what you got oh yeah
ah derek cage for / s getting gear seems
to be a very slow garden it's not that
slow did you get a lot of boxes right
yeah i mean like we've been playing for
like not maybe not even a week and we've
gotten a look at this yeah look at
Batman Marcel uh the Plessis awesome
stream guys thanks for answering
questions yep thank you for tuning in
and watching and oh that oh yeah
intro that interest so good can you do
Harley worse Batman sure we can try I'm
not very good with Harley but we can
definitely try I wish I had the fireball
and move on this on this flash I don't
even have it on my flash
Oh
I should move this so cool just wish
that's oh
swept the leg oh you can you can walk
combo that okay
okay I'm gonna cross stuff oh yeah
swagged on guess wag down again oh I
really was you're gonna either burn that
oh god ah crap
Oh went low right in the junk ran the
junk
combo nice followed up
I don't know how who is that in the
background that is Superman
gotta keep them in jail dang it
good I'm just getting OH I forgot the
meter right now oh so slow come here
that's nice yeah so after that one you
can do the up the up grapple and then me
to run the grapple - Oh after the yeah
so after that after the better bet not
the battery before the battering Mary
Ellen's pretty good I didn't play them
as good oh yeah sherry we can turn up
the audio or the gameplay uh I'm not
good with Aquaman I can try he feels
really slow for me just turned up the
gameplay audio hopefully that helped you
guys how many characters in the game
that's a $20 29 you got the good maths
they want to Harley Harley you want did
you have you later
you play a tiny bit okay okay I'll play
Blue Beetle oh you want some Swamp Thing
okay just one thing I haven't played any
Swamp Thing let's go what if Mario is in
this Creek area it's a me I don't know
how good Mario would be okay can you
imagine getting punched in the face in
slow motion
Beatriz Supergirl firestore know solomon
grundy now something on a tuesday that
was pretty cool voice lion-o oh my god
yeah his jump is really weird
Oh get along but do a back two three two
yeah like the second one comes down and
they've just three two three back to
sing alternates say has routine three
that was like back to three to three
Oh back
the way flanger full-screen command
grabs what is her deal
oh how did that win that's fullscreen
oh that reach
what is join the flowers do I think if I
step in that all the dogs who let the
dogs out but those are hyenas huh yeah
all right clearly I don't know how to
play this the swamps Oh to hit combo Oh
his friend or I think that's just
himself oh that feels like Oh slap me
with a with a branch tentacle I wish I
could fly to be sick gotcha
dang that's great hyena usage oh the
mallet
nice low I do after that
wake up dad how did you know to block
hello I played him what can be done ah -
I'll play Atrocitus if I can remember
how later Dayton she's got the UH the
Rekha's I don't even know what they are
Brett ruler why just curious why are you
not using the special abilities I was
trying I just don't know what his does
I've never play Swamp Thing yo use the
specials to blank can you show me some
bein game spot please
I wouldn't play some bein you know how
play Vayne I know but I'm like oh yeah
with what I've seen from him is like
really cool he's got some like cool
throws y'all need to do Braniac vs. dark
side later okay when do they want to
across use the special try to use the
specials that's why I like Superman you
just use his special and he gets
stronger
alright poison ivy I'll try to do some
poison ivy I'm not a huge fan of Black
Canary I didn't like her in the beta
look he's got some what's the little
cool move Jesus that's not it that's not
it that forward okay
what's the pool of blood oh there is
okay okay now we get no good guys okay
man we're not good
ah too early Oh Dax get out here shoot
fireballs at him Bain is like oh my god
he if I do his character power
he just gets stronger like once his uh
his oh my god Rekha's
yeah Rekha's Gil McVean they do this
pawn I'm do see she's caught my cat
friend out Oh how'd you like that okay
like my deck boss
the damage
not like this he's got like more the
best supers in the game village
Derek Cage saying or Derek cog a maybe
I've led a bunch of single fights and
first two chapters the story I got like
six pieces of gear that's pretty sweet
are you switching characters oh I guess
so try him again
oh yeah well too bad hey Green Arrow be
nice it's not one of his mains oh let's
see
I will play poison ivy because I said I
do see one wash I don't know this is a
lot of ah we can try doing supers we've
done so it's just all the meter man like
how about meter burners all right we did
it super oh yeah sorry I thought you
were saying Superman whoops all right
we're gonna play a few more matches if
you guys have any last not last but if
you guys have any more questions or
anything like that please feel free to
shoot them over your resume getting work
yeah thank you guys for tuning in again
on twitch YouTube and GameSpot if you
haven't followed and subscribed and all
that fun stuff please do that so you
guys get informed on when we go live and
all our cool content and justice include
yep keep me safe
little Boop so Robins got those
batteries they're different each time
and they do different things she not
have a like one two three link was
squared
huh
uh-uh
[Music]
hey that's stupid hug thing
yeah I got mine
ah
my supposed to chase that
oh how did I do that okay
goodness
oh dang it
where are the loot boxes we opened a
bunch of already earlier oh I got you
yeah right Batarang oh no what oh man
you're lucky
go ahead you can have you did catch me
anyways I was pretty cool he couldn't
eat and cancel right out of the
telephone teleport yeah that's a pretty
good one
we'll play dark side Donald sharp will
try it I'm gonna get you at this little
dude no no ya hate that thing it's
pretty good it's pretty annoying cuz you
got to hit her to like make it go away
or wait it out sorry that was probably
low tier so we haven't got any gear
though hmm
I'm saying you are level 3 on this
account yeah I guess that's true
supposed to play dark side like I said
get Brainiac imma try it please in the
game I get a I control he's pretty good
uh an chat asking is there mobile
console unlocks I think there are some
um I haven't seen too much between the
two games but I haven't used the mobile
app enough mr. Wray Wray Han Solo hi or
hey few questions can you buy premiere
skins and DLC or can you only get them
the ultimate education you can buy from
your skins with sword crystals I collect
knowledge which you can also buy with
money if you just want to alright I
gotta figure out how do I shoot the
lasers yes and I make it go up
I'm sure you can
what's the up one goes back baby no back
is that one oh that is you got all you
got everything covered buddy
get out of here second zone
okay take it slow ding all right
Darkseid's uh special abilities for
equal I don't know if it's random
or you can sum in different ones like
that one's gonna explode I'm pretty sure
if I trigger together like this like
sure all right we want this
oh here you come that link you do that
bed beam you get you can actually
control it once it starts coming out
alright looking like if they're jumpy
you can like go around and like up in
the air or like go like around it and
hit them in the back or something maybe
with meter room
Oh like that little to hit combo with my
little pet guy maybe I even do not very
smart the Omega beams fan begins a shake
fan 14 that's correct
I dude the level 20 darkside when I
fought him in the multiverse that's all
he did to me you just zoned me and read
my mind
he incepted my mind and you and now you
have become him yeah exactly
alright uh Captain Cold
are you guys gonna lie Sheen Tekken
probably oh yeah we are gonna do a
Tekken livestream later this month it's
gonna be on arcade cabinets that's all I
got tell you guys there's gonna be more
on that in the future I don't even know
if I was supposed to tell you there
uncle arcade cabinets but whatever
whoops
uh cover everyone here Oh No so uh no no
there's plenty I will go captain captain
hi I don't think you can control the
beam I couldn't control it
I was trying the directional I didn't
look at the move list maybe with um
meter burn you can kind of control it
though you can control the the super
that's the one you can do oh that worry
we say yeah oh you mean after when I
triggered it would you trigger so yeah
you can move it around and it lasts for
so long like I've had I've like had to
go off screen and then have it come back
as well oh sorry the character under the
question mark is Darkseid here I just
took her it I got rid of the PIP I just
want a green lantern - doctor are you
gonna be how Hal Jordan I got Jon
Stewart oh how dare you have a premiere
stage oh I'll play some dead shot Nathan
no which is bull doubt you thought
Darkseid was bad huh double dead shot
who can out zone who carrying that gun
doesn't make you a badass this gun can
stop the flash
good thing I'm the Green Lantern Wow
okay what do I do with Greenlanders Oh
what do I be with captain Cole oh you
clearly come on Dan captain Cole this
short Oh
get ice bald I got my own wall oh that's
what the computer does you got to like
charge up his stupid gun get away from
me as well Oh what did that do I think
that turns me cold I don't know okay oh
nice cool gun ooh
use that for mix-ups okay so you have to
hold his special ability to like to
build up the gun meter yeah that's like
reloaded or whatever yeah but you can
hold it like that okay
oh I just use both meters of it god I
wish I knew I was doing same here
yeah what do you like yeah alright here
we go
designed this gun myself oh yeah I
wonder if that hurts me when you get
close awarded the spike go that I'm
supposed to protect me like you missiles
don't mind me no I had the huh come on
uh ghost conjuring me uh Joey has Beats
Tour motor areas I want to see some
wonder woman alright let's do that
oops
you got to set things up with cat bro I
wish I could do a better job flick I
can't set up anything with that
character because I haven't played them
at all have you played Wonder Woman cuz
I haven't played it wonderful Oh No
aside from story mundo then I won't play
Blue Beetle against you
Oh black Adam alright why I'm gonna
fight for the beetle cuz I can kind of
playful beetle fighters approaching
Atlantis it's got nice lightning bolts
now no ya don't even do I think I sold a
lot of his gear because I don't think I
would so yeah Oh Deadshot alright well
end in one or two matches oh we got to
play cheetah - oh yeah I played dr. fate
already yeah get away
I'm faster oh okay
hmm
oh this rod misses that shot that sounds
like a serval dark rod Oh Oh my toes
let's follow that up what is this
character power
okay yeah I remember
oh it didn't meet her birth because I
didn't meet her burning oh please I'm
gonna hit yes okay I'm gonna take that
shot I guess now I'm going to Wonder
Woman oh I don't know you can go
Deadshot you go - I'll go Grodd I'll go
grad you go get it double dead Shawn no
it's just gonna be awful viewing
experience I mean grodd's gonna get
owned in this matchup but well let's see
if I can get he booked the spam the spam
you know how to do it No
ah we'll pick dr. fate and we pick him
earlier I'm just trying to get through
some characters for you guys even though
we're not doing necessarily the best job
of showing off their tool kit but we
pushed it up a bunch of official
character breakdowns if you're curious
about certain characters on our YouTube
channel so check those out Tony Wilson
and Joey have done a good job putting
those up those were NetherRealm streamed
ones that kind of give you a better
breakdown of look at me
inch by inch oh I need a joke dude the
recovery on this is ridiculous
see how I was itching my way up there
dude that's such a floaty ass jump you
know I guess a gorilla is or grodd's
icon strange what is he what does this
thing do people were saying in comments
for like the video or it shows um sonic
Fox is doing this for like 80 minutes oh
my god I can't jump over it he looks
like a puff nice I can hear anything
daddy dance I seriously can't jump over
it it's too floaty oh my yeah I
apologize in advance no no no this is a
good learning a sonic Fox - it is the
day one patch out yet don't worry I'm
gonna see me creeping keep the sneak ah
you didn't even you jerk me you didn't
even do any trick shots I don't know yes
what does it even do switch stances this
is not a dead shot dance oh my god
oh I got a catchy tune it's gonna
perfect me Jesus this isn't justice two
guys
oh I thought I had the time ago Jesus
what does this even do yeah right okay
no more that uh it's just for proof of
concept right here so DDL why vnm yes -
meter burn does a big role for it the
problem is I couldn't even dashboard to
do the meter burn because he would just
lock me now I might have been able to
time it better but still it's like very
like that's very hard to figure out I
think they're gonna delay probably the
the misciagna the recovery of recovery
is ridiculous at garage straight he can
uh I think he can levitate at when he
gets like a psychic powers all I know is
that sucks
Wonder Woman I'll go cheetah cheetah I
just uh
I was trying to do the four roles I add
but like I said as I was trying to
initiate the - unless I wasn't doing it
fast enough he would hit me before I
could even do it but maybe I didn't do
it right
so that's possible we're going to do
like one maybe two matches and that's it
I'm kind of going on for a bit here
we've got some stuff we got to work on
and streams to work on sorry if I just
talked over that we played star side
earlier
press 1 2 3 4
what does that keep longer claws think
is there more damage or hey look at that
Wolverine legit oh oh you got a combo
after that man oh nice nice use of the
wood not sure no no you were totally
trying to do that you're showing the
mechanics of so you can are two out of a
wall a wall downs I don't do that one oh
that okay yep no you gotta ooh mm oh I
didn't know that was gonna wall down
hmm oh she got that Kiku oh I did not
see that coming Oh take that car dang
that is really fun yo gee that's pretty
fun ooh me likey
she's pretty fun BAM hammers dead shot
that's not going to change anything
last match should be main burst main
that's pretty that's pretty true that's
for you
do we like miss anything here kind of
days far as like the other parts of the
game or just characters cyborg Callen
yeah let's just go let's just go me and
Bruce mean all right
I can either play Batman or Superman
that's all I got so chat I'm gonna let
you decide who you want and Sheila's
replying just press buttons do flash
versus reverse flash Batman or Superman
I can only really play - I know there's
delay so you guys will eventually get
there
come on is it gonna be nobody nobody
nobody intent all right Superman it is
Oh one Batman
I'm better with Superman
Green Arrow yeah because a man Komi to
Superman I mainly because I'm better
with Superman
all right so I think Asylum got more bad
whichever way whatever you're better at
okay yeah my Batman's alright uh I don't
have all the combos yet down I heard you
killed the other me that was an accident
like the one you're about to be in do
you can take him I can't take him
seriously that ice shot huh
the ice too
mmm overhead
Oh oh no it's the normal one I thought
is the meteor one that I have on my ps4
Oh shine up man
ah but a wasted meter oh what a nice
block low
I
we could do twice sure all right best
two out of three best to us yeah I love
this last thing thanks Clash of the West
all right as close I'm going to oh so I
got a bronze box and I got oh because
I'm leveling up Superman huh
you got fur no cuz I leveled up on this
that's what it was because I'm level 5
now on your account or your thing his
overhead was annoying AF I broke my
controller one time fighting hams again
Superman
I was actually yeah you Chi means I'll
show you the oh god this one pry that
and press buttons can't do that oh
please be too far get out I can't
there's gotta be a way to get out of
that sooner mashing it
oh this with a boxing glove arrow yeah
stop wrong I still have it them just
zone you
[Music]
oh come on mind if I take a selfie
what about Batman alright we'll do one
more I'm Batman
last one yeah last one that's it Batman
that's it
I gave it's like that one more match
mentality that I can't oh yeah you can
go the slippery road yeah you go [ __ ]
kind of makes sense right yeah it makes
sense
I'm gonna put you into the asylum okay
it always sucks to lose a controller you
know Ollie was a controller I failed
this city says Green Arrow you failed
him
sorry still should skip roll it so good
idea Fred may Joey oh my god the reach
that hit for 150
Oh No
thinking too hard I was blocked don't
want to teleport Oh
oh that's nice oh look that range
oh I supposed to throw those that you're
not wrong come on scarecrow Oh
Oh
all right you want to run back no gosh
we're good we're done Batman always
prevails kids just remember good always
triumphs over evil
but anyways check out the live stream
here if you didn't catch all of it we
went through a lot of stuff we opened a
bunch of loop boxes we played the
multiverse we showed off our more
customization we showed off some of the
AI combat some of the guild stuff join
the guild if you have it it's a GS or
GameSpot I think it might be full oh you
mean we we've reached 50 mils right I
think you you can uh like assign
officers and stuff like thank you in
like two people okay well if it's full
it's full sorry about that but thanks
again hit the follow button on Twitch
hit the subscribe button on YouTube if
you haven't ra so you guys get notified
when we go live and when we enjoy our
opening boxes again but uh otherwise
Thank You Joey
Thank You Diane Thank You stream
remember check out peter brown's review
9 out of 10 for injustice spoilers 9 out
of 10 and join us tomorrow at 11 for the
lobby I think they're talking a little
bit about injustice too and some other
topics as well and I think we're going
to try streaming Farpoint of VR tomorrow
at 2 o'clock that's that PlayStation VR
game where it has like a like a plastic
gun thing that's pretty cool so yeah
check that out and uh thanks for again
for watching guys later